hi my name is Kelly Clarkson and I feel
honored and super cheesy because I love
Conan about being Conan O'Brien's friend
well that's very sweet thank you very
much that's very nice and I will warn
you
Kelly it's apparently not a very
sentimental crowd tonight
I tried to just bully them into
saying something romantically make them
cry exactly do it do it you know I kept
talking about this but I was I said I
know I've met
Kelly and it was right after you burst
into the world's attention with American
Idol you came on my late night show and
I watched the clip of it this morning I
did too and I was freaked out oh not me
winning me on your show sorry yeah oh
okay yeah yeah yeah no no I'm saying I
watched the clip of you coming on my
show yes okay I only watch things that
involve me and they said don't you want
to see Kelly the night she won I'm like
no I'm not in it
the first thing that struck me is you
are a kid you're like a child you come
out and then I'm an 11 year old girl in
the in this CL I mean I am just such I'm
So Young too and I'm like hey it's Kelly
Clarkson anybody and okay so that's how
I felt like my voice sounded so we we
literally I was telling him earlier we
we Google it because I was like I know
it was like right after Idol that was so
excited like in love with him like I've
like I was very excited and so what
happened I mean
no no I mean I mean just at that moment
I was like I cannot believe I was so
excited to get to do your show so I was
like I did it was a huge thing and I'd
never done anything like that the only
thing I'd done is Idle really so I was
very excited and um but I we looked it
up I was like I feel like it was like
2003-ish and we looked it up and that
was so it's 20 years ago yeah so we have
a date in 20 years
to have another interview we were
allowed to speak to each other once
every once every 20 years it's allowed
um but no but I I had to turn it off
because my voice was you hate your own
voice like your talking voice like I
don't leave voicemails I hate my talking
voice you don't wait a minute to a
degree that you don't leave a voicemail
I never leave a voicemail how do you
feel about being on a podcast
here's why here's why I'm okay with this
show and here's why I'm okay with my
talk show or any show I do because I
don't watch them or listen to myself
back because I'm in it okay like you
experienced so I don't ever we were just
sexually discussing this I never watched
myself so for that reason alone like do
you like your voice when you hear your
voice nobody really does right I am uh I
am not a fan of my voice but then I talk
to other people and they agree that
they're also not a fan
and I've always thought I do not have a
good voice for television or radio and
and that's the medium that I got into
and which by the way reminds me I have a
major bone to pick with you which is I
got into being a talk show host because
that's the one thing I could do oh you
became a talk show host and you're
really good at it and you have so many
other incredible possibilities and
you're an amazing singer that enrages me
it just enrages me because that was all
I could do no one else was saying you
know why don't you do you also have like
a 10 octave range yeah but I think I'll
just do a talk show you know whether
you're on a cross-country drive or on
your daily commute time in the car is
perfect for listening to podcasts like I
don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip some
times I do too and I have T-Mobile and I
ca I can honestly say there's coverage
that's important like there's been times
in my life where I'm out on the road
driving around and uh especially on
those family trips you're out in the
desert you want to make sure you have
that coverage yeah what if you get like
your car breaks down and you're just
there sitting there like a chump yeah no
coverage yeah not this guy I've got
T-Mobile got 5G find out more at
t-mobile.com Cy that's
s-e-e-w-h-y I have been very vocal about
this from the very beginning like I was
more shocked than anyone like after
doing the voice they were like oh we
like how you are on the show your energy
like we think you do great at a talk
show you we have this idea and I was
like oh thank you no
um you said no initially twice because I
was like I do not think that people will
I am not a comedian I am not a
journalist I have no experience to do
this like literally why would you want
me to do this like and so they they
really my ex actually really pushed me
to do it he was like I think you'll be
really good at it and I was like
okay I was like and so I tried it and I
will say from the pilot
I think as long as you're a curious
person and you love to engage with
people you love to be communicative like
it's
it's kind of an easy job like it's like
it's fun I would say I can I I sometimes
think I can predict who's gonna be good
at it and when I heard that you were
going to do a show my first instinct was
you were very you're a very warm person
and you're very uh you seem like a real
person and then I when I bumped into
people that work with you regularly
including the woman who did my makeup
today who worked yeah she was just
saying she's the best she's such a nice
person and I think that is half of it is
if you can be yourself in front of
people and you're legitimately good
person it's going to work out and so you
have I mean you are yourself and you're
comfortable then it doesn't really
matter like because you don't know
because I didn't know like people told
me afterwards like wow it was successful
like that never happens and I was like
come again and then and they were like
oh this was probably gonna fail and I
was like what like they didn't tell you
that up front I had no I like ignorance
was 100 isn't Bliss I had no idea that
statistically I was screwed like it was
like I was probably gonna fail so I was
like if I had known that maybe I would
have said no a third time no the only
way what happens in Show Business is
they'll kill you with enthusiasm so what
happens is everyone's like it's gonna be
the best you're just gonna be amazing
it's the perfect choice for you perfect
time and what they're really thinking is
I don't know yeah if it goes badly
that's their problem yeah
yeah and so uh you just you know but
yeah I'm glad I didn't know yeah it's
best not to know yeah and you just enjoy
it and you do it because you like doing
it yeah the um I'm curious because I
want to go way back to
um when I'm speaking to them in a room
it's not being recorded I often have my
back turned this is the first time we've
seen his face yeah yeah and they're not
pleased yeah what's interesting to me
now is that you know American Idol and a
bunch of these different singing shows
like the voice they become such a
regular part of the fabric I remember
very clearly
um and I was in New York and I was doing
the Late Night show and I remembered
seeing um an advertisement for this
brand new show called American Idol and
not knowing what it was and then hearing
it's a singing competition show and like
anyone else thinking well that'll be
around for 10 minutes for 10 minutes
yeah like everything else yeah and I'm
always wrong about things so I uh of
course it went on to be huge but what's
interesting is your perspective on it as
the first person I'm just curious to
hear you talk about the beginning the
very beginning of American Idol I know
there was some stuff at the very
beginning where it almost felt like
these people don't really know what
they're doing like this company doesn't
know what they're doing because they're
just figuring it out for the first time
well because that that there's truth to
that because it had pop Idol which was
in the UK
um Will Young won the first one and that
was kind of the big thing and it blew up
there in the United Kingdom and then
Simon Fuller was not Cal Fuller
um was like oh I'm gonna do this in
America and see how it goes over well
they weren't sure and so it blew up and
they didn't really know how to control
it I don't know if you've noticed but
geographical speaking America is
enormous compared to the UK so covering
all that ground and like all the outlets
and like all I mean we were literally
someone was always sick with like
walking or like laryngitis or just so we
were over work not and not because they
were mean about it everybody just didn't
know it was a phenomenal it was just a
phenomenon so it just blew up and
everybody was just trying to keep up
with it right I heard I heard I don't
know if it's true that that they so this
is the level they were at they took you
guys to a mall the contestants to a mall
this is true and I've heard this and it
just sounds I mean now you know that
they have a whole system because it's
become part of the show business
on the show until I think like the top
five maybe right so you guys were just
doing your own makeup and hair dropped
us at a mall the Beverly Center
and oh that
gave us money and said and it was like I
don't I think it was like 200 bucks I
don't even know how it was just like a
couple hundred dollars or something like
that and and said okay go go you know
you this is you you know a prize to go
get something like for you know the show
and I am thinking this Show's going
nowhere I'm pocketing this money I will
wear whatever I want
I just wore what I had so what did you
so you so you didn't even spend the
money they gave you no I didn't I was
like this is like rent money I was like
I'm not gonna waste it on this dumb mall
and like who cares about I didn't know
no one knew the show would be what it
was I'm literally the first winner I had
no idea like no one knew even after I
won no one knew no one could have called
that right I do think the reason why so
many successful people are from that
particular show is because they're so
invested Simon Fuller like with the
company the record company the
management right the show like if one
succeeds all the others succeed so I
that's the Brilliance behind that
um and honestly I had a wonderful time
like I love Simon Fuller this never
happens in the industry but like he
actually let me out of my deal
and he didn't have to and I was you know
successful so there was no reason to do
that but he actually let me out because
he he couldn't actually be there
um it was like other people running it
and it just wasn't a good um that's
unheard of in anything I haven't heard
of in any business but specifically the
music business for someone to say this
is a superstar a major Talent she wants
out you can I was at MTV Iced Out
performing and I was just in tears on
the phone I'm going look I I love you
you're like the kindest person ever but
like I don't work with you on the
regular and I'm just unhappy with who I
am working with and he not only said
he'd let me out he also said he'd help
me find management and help me out like
after like and with no with no ask like
nothing no strings so it's I had a very
positive experience in that sense right
I will point out he sounds like a
terrible businessman he's really loaded
so he's doing something right once once
I was like friends and I randomly like
went like backpacking like um you know
in France and he was like literally this
is a real story it was like he was like
oh are you near and I was like oh my God
you're here too and he was like yeah he
was like I'll send my tender for you and
I was like
I'm sorry what I was like what is it and
this is before the app tender this is a
a boat I guess a tiny boat with a bigger
boat that comes to get you and I was
like I know but it contains another boat
it's a tiny boat I guess from one big
yacht to like come get and I was like oh
man we roll in different circles
you're backpacking with your friends and
it's like you're gonna stay in a youth
hostel and then this guy's like I'll
send my yacht over
definitely a normal Hotel like it was a
husband with a normal hotel and I just
was like oh my God you're good like
that's not I don't I feel like a pretty
woman like you know you walk in the
store and you don't belong
um so I was like oh this is not this is
not how I roll so no I'm good but I
learned what a tender was